anyhow remember when i said i was gonna
review a movie or two that
it has that halloween vibe but i
wouldn't call it a halloween movie
i don't know i don't know if this is
guilty pleasure or just pleasure but
let's talk about it
constantine so constantine stars keanu
reeves it came out in 2005 and it's
based off of the comic book character
from vertigo comics constantine
it's based off of the comic books the
hell blazer kind of i mean it is
but it's not it's kind yeah
it's best i can say it i mean i suppose
it doesn't really follow it
but neither did the jurassic park movie
follow the jurassic park
book so it doesn't matter it doesn't
always matter oh god i'm rambling so
constantine's this dude who when he dies
he's gonna go straight to hell
you know because catholic lore
constantine dogma what is it about
catholic lore being the thing that well
it is pretty fast it's interesting stuff
give it to the catholics man you guys
you took that christian lore and you ran
with it made it epic
it's like video game worthy or comic
book worthy
movie adaptation of comic book and here
we are so constantine is a guy he sees
and knows
the world that we remain ignorant to and
we do not see
that is the world of heaven hell angels
and demons and half breeds and influence
and
well constantine just spends his life
sending demons back to hell
and his keanu reeves carry this movie
probably absolutely it's keanu reeves
keanu reeves is one of those dudes he
just
he knows the movie he's making and he
just commits
and constantine is one of those i feel
underrated keanu reeves roles where it's
like
for what they were going for in this
movie he was perfect
not that this character is actually like
constantine from the comic books like
best i can
describe comic book constantine which
matt ryan amazingly plays
he always will for anyone who has
constantine
in their show or movie or video game or
whatever and they're smart enough to
cast him
and they should be constantine's british
kiana reeves is bloody wolves chasing me
through some blue inferno
decidedly not and comic book constantine
has that british cynicism and american
keanu reeves constantine has that very
american cynicism
welcome to my life this is the best i
can describe it if i just had to sum it
up right there i don't know i just love
him and i feel like keanu reeves
absolutely does
carry it with his performance of the
character and the character because
constantine in this movie he's a guy who
just he doesn't care
it's such a liberating freeing thing
seeing a character or a person in real
life
who's just free of giving a [ __ ] i love
seeing characters like that they're
unbridled they're free
to be human he's so matter-of-fact
so damaged and so you can tell the guy
is not
fulfilled but you get it you understand
that he's not fulfilled he he
knows he has seen the great and powerful
oz behind the curtain he knows how all
of it works
this world is just a fleeting thing and
nothing in it's gonna fulfill this guy
he deals on another level than the rest
of us deal and that will probably
shatter a person and i love the world
i'm a sucker for lore and this movie has
great lore
diamond huntsu plays papa midnight
probably my favorite character in the
movie i love characters like him he's
just
there's this heaven and hell war going
on here on earth that most people aren't
even aware of and he owns this bar where
he just kind of stays out of it and
angels demons good bad anybody's welcome
there the fight
is not there it's it's neutral ground
you know the rules of my house
while here you will abide by them it's
like holy ground in highlander or any
youtube channel trying to survive this
climate and i gotta give this movie
marks for making hell look
miserable you know cause hell is
supposed to be miserable right we're not
supposed to want to go there sometimes
you see hell and you're like that
actually looks kind of cool
or it's kind of enticing you know like
oh whoa three
hot vampire succubus gonna come over and
[ __ ] my brains out for eternity oh no
man better be good in life no this looks
like a shitty
burnt dry sandstorm version of this
world and when you're dealing with a
shittier version of this world no thanks
i thought rachel wise was fine in the
movie but she's really
she's the civilian you know she's the
one being let in
on this world she's basically there to
be our eyes
actually i don't know if civilian is the
right word she has thus far been as
ignorant to this
supernatural world as the rest of us and
that she serves as our eyes and ears
into the world she's a good actor and
she was good in the movie not as the
movie doesn't have problems if you're
a constantine hellblazer parish you
might be like that's not
really constantine don't know if that's
a problem but it's worth addressing i do
feel like there's
a whole other movie before this movie
that we just never
saw you hear about how papa midnight was
this badass witch doctor at one point
constantine was the john constantine
once
not anymore though you're like what i'd
like to see that world a little bit
maybe they were planning on going back
and showing it i don't know but it never
happened that said i do like this phase
here because i love it when
people who are so badass and so hailed
have kind of fallen from grace and
they're just
these damaged people now dated cgi in
this movie
that's for sure yeah in that phase of
the 2000s we were like we can do
anything
now we could just cgi it and now we look
back we're like
we could but we didn't stop to think if
we should i do love lucifer in this
movie he's amazing doesn't hurt that
it's peter stormair and regardless of
the movie
i can't think of a role he's played
where he didn't just crush it point is
he's such a
weirdo as lucifer which is funny because
it's constantine
which is in the vertigo world which is
with sandman which is with lucifer
of lucifer morningstar fame yeah that
charming bastard well
he's this guy now doesn't matter don't
care just thinking out loud because i
just love him as lucifer
peter stormer is having fun playing
lucifer and most importantly
he's memorable he's only in this movie
for a few minutes but when i think about
this movie
he's one of the top characters and
performances i think about it's one of
those movies even if you're not watching
it if it's on
i'll just i'll keep it there i'm like oh
yeah constantine maybe i'm watching it
maybe i'm doing other stuff but i like
having it on in my house
and that's what i love about this movie
is keanu reeves taking on demons
not doing it by the book not doing it as
a priest would you know buy the bed with
an old priest and a young priest and the
power of christ compels you now he's
doing it with cynicism his wits and a
small arsenal of modern badass fantasy
gear that only a movie like this can
deliver it's not a perfect movie call it
guilty pleasure but i'm just saying this
movie's always a fun time no alcohol
required all right so constantine have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite
guilty pleasure movie of halloween
spirit doesn't have to be guilty
pleasure just pleasure but you know
those movies
it's like most people watching this are
probably like
i didn't know he's going to review that
the exorcist is out there there are some
classics but sure jeremy constantine and
damn it i wanted to talk about this
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you